coming up it won't feel like a sunday in
a week and a half because on sunday
night football
you'll see the cleveland browns yes the
cleveland browns coming to nbc not
because they were scheduled to be their
shireen back in april or early may this
year when the schedule came out but
because of the flex option for the first
time since the nfl adopted the flex
protocol in 2006
the browns are being flexed into prime
time and
the dallas cowboys
are being flexed out
what indeed is this world coming to when
america's team is out
and the chronically inept cleveland
browns are insuring
unbelievable mike first time ever the
cowboys have been flexed out of a sunday
night game as you said nbc took it over
in 2006 and they'll play the fewest
sunday games they have ever played in
their history two how about that mike if
if there is a sobering fact whatever for
jerry jones this is it you're you're not
america's team anymore right you're not
playing in prime time on national tv you
got flexed out and so he's gonna have
some big decisions to make at the end of
the year but nice to see the giants and
browns who would have thought on that
prime time dates in a couple weeks
because the giants usually the last few
years we've seen them in week one
against the cowboys on sunday night that
typically is the kickoff game it wasn't
this year was cowboys rams but we have
seen the giants play the cowboys that
sunday night game and then we usually
don't see them anymore they haven't been
good the last few years so fun to see
some teams that we don't normally see
we'll get to see them and i think it'll
be a great game
cowboys giants was the game not that
long ago and for a long time that the
networks would engage in a tug of war
over sunday night football wanted it fox
wanted it at 4 25 eastern cbs tried to
horn in on it when they came up with the
cross flex monday night football wanted
it and they spread it around as best
they could now anyone
would
would pass on cowboys giants in a prime
spot although maybe with the giants
leading the nfc east they would want it
for the giants sake and the double
benefit here is the nbc game becomes
browns and a giants team that has a
gigantic market and a team that is
relevant and is contending for a
division championship it's the second
time this year the cowboys have been
disrespected this way remember the
packers colts game got moved to 4 25 p.m
eastern and they actually sent
the top broadcasting team was that a
week that romo and company was at an
aikman week either way the former
cowboys quarterback wasn't at the
cowboys game it was cowboys vikings one
of the only games the cowboys have won
recently that uh that fell out of the
top spot but you know
about a year and a half ago i
interviewed stephen jones and asked him
in a very
admirable
i mean admiring way not admirable the
question wasn't admirable but the tone
was admiring got to get that right if i
did maybe i didn't how is it that the
cowboys can continue to have such a
great following when they haven't been
to an nfc championship game in 25 years
and you know what
maybe that
pumpkin oh wait what is it the chariot
turns into a pumpkin maybe it's a
pumpkin after 25 years and maybe now is
the time when people won't continue to
flock to cowboys games if the product
they're getting is unacceptable
and you're kicked out by the browns of
all teams i mean yeah that that that's
that's crazy mike that that would be the
case but still look back at that
thanksgiving day game and it's still the
highest rated game um
yet a regular season game and it's the
highest rated tv show since the super
bowl so they still draw but you know i
think it's more people liking to see
them lose probably than cowboys fans
tuning in because they know what's going
to happen with this team but this team
is terrible i i would say it's one of
the worst at least the bottom five of
the league and that's why they're not
playing on sunday night football in a
couple weeks it's gonna be the browns
and the giants who are playing much
better football and i think just a
couple weeks ago mike we thought this
cowboys team was one that could turn it
around and perhaps win the nfc east as
bad as it was and instead it's been
washington and the giants who've managed
to turn it around and look like real nfl
teams that could do some damage in the
postseason especially considering one of
them will get that home game to start
the postseason
two quick points and then we move on
first i believe that any two nfl teams
playing in that time slot on
thanksgiving and also in that stadium
because i think there's something
special about the dallas cowboys home
stadium hosting a a thanksgiving
mid-afternoon game we're so used to that
just that image that that visualization
that comes from
uh att stadium i think you put any two
teams in the nfl on that spot and you
get the same number on that day that
afternoon that's just part of the
thanksgiving tradition it would look
weird to not have the cowboys as one of
the teams especially at a t stadium but
i think it's more about the moment and
the circumstance than it is about the
cowboys finally
august 5 2016
i i wrote on a piece of paper and i
sealed in an envelope not to be open
until august 5 2021 that when i opened
at this little mini time capsule i've
devised that the browns will be regarded
as a better organization top to bottom
than the cowboys and it it it didn't
look good for a while because there was
an oh and 16. now in these last few
years i do want to yeah open it yeah
it's i gotta wait i gotta wait till
august but it's finally looking good
this is the moment where it's finally
looking good uh and the giants uh they
believe it's looking good for daniel
jones to play
this weekend with the hamstring injury i
just don't get it i don't see it i think
you have to give a hamstring time to
heal unless you are going to basically
immobilize him in the pocket and
instruct him to do nothing put him in
shotgun the whole game so he never has
to try to run on that leg and and
re-injure the hamstring i can't imagine
he would come back you have to give him
the time to rest if you want him to be
ready to go for the playoff stretch run
if there is a postseason stretch run for
the giants to have shereen
and maybe it would have been different
mike if they had lost last week but you
sent colt mccoy out there and he beat
the seahawks and i do realize how bad
the seahawks defense is 31st in the nfl
and total defense i get that but he
played well enough i'm not going to say
he was great he played well enough for
the giants to win and that defense can
carry them so yeah i'm with you i think
you let that thing fully heal he was
limited at practice today
but you got to be sure that he could
protect himself in the pocket and it and
it also you know the thing that makes
daniel jones daniel jones is his
mobility and if he can't move and get
outside the pocket and run for you he's
our second leading rusher right now if
he can't do all those things i'm
starting colt mccoy
i agree with you completely and anybody
that's had a hamstring injury and it's
one of the various injuries i've had
over the years you think it's healed
until you try to open it up and then you
feel it grab and you're set back and and
you don't want that because then you
have more time that you're going to miss
they need to let this thing heal
completely time is the key element and
there's all sorts of other things they
can do at an nfl facility to speed it
along but don't don't put him on the
field until he is fully and completely
recovered
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports